you don't know that
he's gonna work out or something but can
you start talking to her like she's not
muslimited maybe you should move away
I was talking to her it's dangerous for
you now yeah maybe the best food if you
have a sister you can contact you sister
to help us understand Islam but we don't
have this boyfriend girlfriend even if
you have like you've got it
as longer for example if I want to marry
his sister yeah
then okay I only knows I'm talking to
how we talked
with invitation of marriage it's
something else but you know
liquor
is talking to her you know
foreign
the parents that isn't going to get
married and interested okay then you
start talking about what you want to you
know about marriage everything there's
no problem with that but yeah
both of them said
I said if both of you have an interest
to get married and you appreciate
approach the father and you speak to the
father then is it permissible to speak
to her on the phone he said I don't have
Father Knows then as long there's a
limit because while you only have
intention to get married and you
approach the father you understand but
but but of course but to be on the safe
side you know you have to know yourself
like you know fatua for example
but I don't use it special it's not
talking about Haram
understand because that fight was not
for you anymore
comes in have a guardian
yes because they have to be your parents
so can it be someone else in the family
as a friend person
Ally
would you be happy for me to come to
your daughter and not approach you about
your brother
and now what you can do like what's up
group
you can have the father in the WhatsApp
so you have Guardian
yeah yeah
but so that's what it's very important
to understand for Tower because
sometimes some people there is a factory
of the island
and they misuse it and they said if
I spoke about you you have to be honest
for example when the Wilderness
said it's permissible for women to go to
Phoenix University out of a necessity it
was about specific system it's not about
every woman
you understand so now not every woman
can get that fit to her and try to apply
to ourselves
so that's why they're still between
effects
the federal and how to implement it
era
you know that's why there's some
sometimes you hear people say
scholarship yeah but it is you have to
understand
you know you have to understand speech
speech of the scholars
so there is
where you can narrate but of course on
the condition that you understand the
factual and you understand how the
federal should be uh or this Federal
should be implemented
you cannot come to uh for example
environment uh let me give examples for
example now in speakers
sometimes you have to speak to women
we ask one of the major Scholars it's
over 95 years old he's teaching Medina
we've asked him about in the Western
World Sometimes women can speak to us
they're not covered what should we do he
says Go cover it first doesn't make any
sense you give that one no doubt okay
so now you cannot take that fat to her
and have a podcast sitting down with the
sisters have a makeup and a phoenix
scene talking and starting with them
because the house in the park is outside
the park is out of necessity
you can't escape it but that word is of
necessity it's not necessity for me to
sit with the sister even if her husband
I mean if a husband there that is worse
I don't know if you accept your wife to
be sitting in front of me talking and
smiling to each other I don't know about
that brother you have to check your Hera
your jealousy I understand you're right
so so the point here is so don't don't
misuse the fact of Ln for example some
Muslim liberals
so there's no problem for sisters to be
online they're giving dollar even with
no no no first thing is to teach where
outside the mission on the street no she
was at her house
secondly she had a curtain you
understand thirdly you can compare
um
foreign
they used to go to the house and the
husband is there and behind the curtain
oh behind the curtain with the other
people
so this is just general advice about the
importance of understanding
and how to implement it you know because
we haven't now people just misuse a
verse misuse Hadi misuse uh
because
her husband is dead that's worse the
husband there and his elasticity with a
man drinking and The Smiling talking
about things and looking at each other
you know
irrelevant yeah so you can't apply that
don't use don't use it for job on the
street and the is somewhere you can
escape
foreign
and I want to also wanted to mention
something you know sometimes my dear
brothers and sisters oh I use the Hadith
and I don't quote word for word in
English because in English you cannot
cook the holy word for what you're
quoting the meaning okay because person
says in Arabic so recently I said the
Hadith
said I came to divide the people but the
Hadith actually says
the Angels were telling to each other
muhammadness
there's two words in for this Hadith so
they said let's talk to each other and
they said
cause people to be divided meaning
between the Believers and the
disbelievers the obedient and
disobedient ones you know so uh
sometimes even when I narrates
in English I got the meaning okay for
example
the Hadith about a person who sit alive
and by the evening misquoting
you know that's why it's very important
to understand spiritual LL
understandable how to know the Hadith
but you know sometimes people Allah
she's a good woman you know and she's uh
not you know to be fornicator having
many boyfriends Chase for FIFA FIFA
chase woman
she's a chase woman yeah
you can marry her but you know there's
enough
but if you can if you're if you
hello
but again there's conditions to it and
you have to know yourself
you know because now if I'm not a Muslim
woman yes
and something happened may Allah forbid
she choose to leave and take the
children or something I'm looking up
there myself because I'm married Muslim
woman
and she's not giving me my right Allah
with all that accountable not everybody
enormous woman
you know and she has it many times here
Brothers my children you know so you
know I mean make sure if you marry
someone from the people of the book
Christian or Jewish no someone tried to
give a damn fast you know yeah
his name is a loud conditions
she's uh protect her
virginity shout out to me version
of the diversion but she's not going to
be for indicator
to protect our private part also she's
not known to have boyfriends
then
yeah so there's conditions to it
how old are you
yeah get married man
yes think about it young Brothers got
married man now we have his fantastic
come back get married
okay how do you know you're gonna live
now get married if you young got married
and maybe let's advise us with this now
it's okay for for a girl she's 14 16. so
I have fornication with every man but to
get married no no that's a crime look
how they promote in glamorizing
glorifying what
evil things when it comes to Halal many
bodies
now even some Muslim parents man you go
a brother goes to Maori but to ask for
the daughter he said she has to finish
finish University
Mariah
you understand and then I see some
parents that contact us in my daughter
she went out she got pregnant at
fornication when her brother came to ask
you for a hand you didn't want to give
up
you know so you know we have to make the
mileage easy
subhanallah now marriage is hard yes but
fornication is okay
you know subhanallah so if you're our
parents and your daughters boys raise
them that they should get married at a
young age
don't let this uh the Western World
deceive You by oh they're still young
are they still young but if they're
foreign
to open their legs for every human being
but they're young to get married
look at hypocrisy
the cute Muslims
my daughter she's still she's still yeah
how much is 55 years old this is a
grandmother man this is not married
even the parents they don't mind
foreign
over his notice
now you know how many sometimes your
families mother guide them they don't
mind their daughters to wear mini skirt
you know
you raise them with a mini skirt then
you ask why they're going to nightclub
you're the problem
raise them to cover themselves
raise them to cover themselves that's
Islamic teaching
I remember once I was a shepherd's Bush
and this old woman English old woman
came to me she said oh we're doing Tower
table she said oh my son I saw a little
girl she was like 10 years old and her
father put a sheep on her I thought so
what's the problem with that I said I
see many girls five seven years old
eight years old they have mini skirts
so why you don't think about that and
then you know there's many people fights
out there
I said the way you want to teach your
children is right for them he wants to
teach his child is right for her it's
okay for you to do that but it's harder
for him uh now if he does it if a Muslim
do it it's brainwashing but if they
teach them for fornication no that's
civilization Mala curse it and may Allah
bless backward if the backwards will be
a real man every woman and may Allah
curse civilization that make you worse
than monkeys and donkeys and the pigs
foreign
blessings
because you know that leads me to Muslim
have the word of terminologies
the war of terminologies
you know when they wanna make women
world of nothing they use her to to sell
their products to to sell cars where
they say women's rights
women's Freedom what does that mean is a
man's freedom to manipulate women to
utilize her as a tool to sell his
products that's what he means but he
cannot say that to her because she won't
even accept so I will use nice
terminology
a nice looking
huh the the proof the that is the way of
shaytan
shape done
what did he say to Adam
why is it to Adam and I'm gonna
look at Allah
so I'll show you the tree of Eternity
and I'll Everlasting Dominion what was
he referring to he was referring to the
tree which Allah made Haram for Adam
you see how he changed the name of the
tree the tree is
experience he never called it what
eternity and everlasting Dominion
and human nature that you want to live
forever that's why even the scientists
destroy up in the jailing they say we're
gonna try to find something to make us
live forever human wants to live ever
but we come and live forever here
because too many troubles too many
calamities the best place to live ever
if you want to live forever is in Jannah
and the worst place
terminologies
feminism where is feminism
defending woman yeah how are you
different woman to make it equal to Man
Woman My Mother proud to be woman
there's certain things about women men
cannot have and certain things
and that will make them
they're married and accomplish each
other
understand
so we have to be careful be careful from
terminology
that's when you start smoking drugs too
much
we should not laugh because mocking
Jesus you should not love this may Allah
guide him or curse him because we come
up Jesus is our messenger you know he's
smoking Jesus he said
idiot
IC
anyway go inside you see
what's happening you okay lady all right
we have sticky lipstick yeah
old now doesn't mean you're old how are
you okay
how's your day been
are you a Muslim
Christians always power and
oppression people and not ego to
everyone no very English is good
but not really oh always somebody of the
top says from Greek you have to do and
love that yeah but you have someone in
this country on the top tell you what to
do too yeah
but it's not good yes but you still have
to listen to them
yeah but the points here
no no we are equal in the sight of God
however things were not equal
time
wait before we go to that I cannot
breastfeed that breastfeed my child no
the woman can do it
okay
so I would say to Auntie look look I
have respect what you have to understand
is not about is if someone on the top or
not if someone on the top and it's
giving us a way of life which is good
for us
please have respect
you are a woman you're a man
it's behind you too
um
please stop watching too much media yeah
yeah
because we defend them like the queen
where is the queen you can always have
Palace
thank you thank you
Islam
so the problem is who's on the top
the opponent is that one is teaching you
what he's teaching is right wrong
listen she's better than you man you are
the devil no you're not the son of the
devil you are the devil Jesus is better
than you
[Music]
she's better than you are son of devil
bitching you're a pagan
you are the devil so is your son
Jesus mighty messenger the true Messiah
Jesus
you see you cannot see the Christian
defending Jesus
we Define Jesus
you know outside